російська армія захопила Херсон ще на
початку березня а на початку жовтня
президент Росії Володимир Путін на
урочистій церемонії оголосив про анексію
чотирьох українських областей у тому
числі і Херсонської аж раптом 9
листопада у Москві офіційно оголосили
про відведення російських військ з
Херсона
є той факт що під час оголошення про
вихід з Херсона не було президента
Путіна те що оголосити про це мали
військові на цьому трохи дивному
брифінгу на якому були присутні зокрема
Генерал і міністр оборони Я думаю що це
такий спосіб дати зрозуміти хто несе
відповідальність за відступ російських
військ і президент Путін хоче дати чітко
зрозуміти що це не він
тим часом у Києві вважають що говорити
про виведення російських військ з
Херсона поки що зарано За словами
радника глави офісу президента України
Михайла подоляка деякі російські
підрозділи досі залишаються у місті і в
регіон стягуються додаткові сили
потрібно розуміти ніхто ні звідки Просто
так не йде якщо не відчуває сили ворог
не робить нам подарунків не робить
жестів доброї волі ми все це виборюємо
А коли в обурюєш треба розуміти що кожен
крок - це завжди спротив ворога це
завжди втрата життів наших героїв тому
ми рухаємось дуже акуратно без емоцій
без зайвого ризику в інтересах
звільнення всієї нашої землі і щоб
втрати були якнайменше Саме так ми
забезпечимо звільнення Херсону Каховки
Донецьку інших наших міст
деякі західні військові аналітики не
виключають що відведення російських
військ з Херсона може бути трюком щоб
заманити Українські сили в пастку
можливо це насправді відхід щоб
перегрупуватися відновитися зібрати сили
та підготувати сюди наступного нападу в
цьому районі або Навпаки це прийом
подивимося правді у вічі ми знаємо що
більшість мирного населення вивезено з
Херсона можливо це прийом з метою
спонукати українців наступати щоб
росіяни могли розпочати Контрнаступ
бронетанковими силами
і не дай боже атакувати тактичною
ядерною зброєю на відкритій місцевості в
районі Херсона нічого не можна виключати
Якби я зараз був українським
головнокомандувачем то дуже б
насторожено ставився до того що
відбувається
я максимально задію би військовий
розвідку щоб з'ясувати що відбувається
на місцевості і я б дуже побоювався
перекидати НАТО багато своїх військ
далеко вперед поки ми не будемо знати що
збирається зробити
росіяни
водночас політики з американського
інституту вивчення війни вважають що
навряд чи оголошення про відведення
російських військ це пастка для того щоб
заманити українські підрозділи в бій під
херсоном адже це загрожує росіянам
великими втратами з цим погоджуються й
експерт кафедри вивчення війни
королівського коледжу Лондона
майк-мартін
вони не оголошували про це по
телебаченню на рівні держави насправді
весь останній місяць Ми бачимо що
російські війська відступають Вони
навіть висадили повітря кілька невеликих
мостів що полегшити собі відступ і вони
також укріпилися на іншому березі Дніпра
створили дуже довгу лінію оборони
у міністерстві оборони Великобританії
вважають що Росія більше не могла
підтримувати свої війська на західному
березі Дніпра через українські удари по
російських маршрутах постачання якщо
Росія справді втратить правий берег з
херсоном це швидше за все завадить
Москві створити сухопутний міст до Одеси
зазначають у британському відомстві
гадаю ми побачимо ще один акт воєнних
дій до того як почнеться зима щойно
почнеться зима усе сповільниться бо
стане значно складніше боротись на таких
ландшафтах як в Україні гадаю Україна
має дві опції одна наступати далі і
визволити цю конкретну ділянку на
правому березі Дніпра це треба робити
дуже-дуже повільно і дуже-дуже обережно
оскільки росіяни неминучі відрізатимуть
шляхи і лишатимуть підрозділи на іншому
березі але Україна також має іншу опцію
якщо Росія забереться з цієї території
чому не спробувати зробити Контрнаступ
на інші на ділянці ми це власне вже
неодноразово бачили з боку засу вони
просуваються вперед і атакують один
регіон а тоді пересувається є такують
інші регіон тому не буде сюрпризом якщо
в наступні два тижні тобто ще до Різдва
ми побачимо контрнаступальні дії
українців в іншому регіоні
тим часом самі українці реагують на
повідомлення про вивід російських військ
з Херсона зі стриманим оптимізмом
росіяни вірити не можна це само собою
Я думаю наші вищі військове керівництво
пропрацьовує різні сценарії ці операції
Ми мусимо чекати офіційних даних Я
вважаю що треба почекати давайте не
будемо бігти по перед батька думаю що
наше керівництво
зсувуване все розраховується аналізують
її розвідка Я теж думаю що вона допоможе
нам і ми не попадемо в цю пастку не
потрапили Мені здається що вони там все
тормозять задля того щоби сформувати
резерви які вони зараз мобілізували і
можливо завдати удару з іншої сторони ми
не виходять їх зупиняють ви їх
витісняють Я вірю в наше ЗСУ вірю в те
що вони їх подолають і Україна буде наша
навіть окуповані території будуть наші
крім наш Донецьк наш Луганськ наш тому я
вірю в краще
віддав належне здобуткам ЗСУ звільнення
українських територій і генсек НАТО й
єнс Столтенберг ми взяли до відома заяву
Росії про відступ з Херсона нам ще треба
зачекати як розвиватиметься ситуація
найближчими днями але ясно що Росія
перебуває під сильним тиском і якщо вони
залишать Херсон то це буде ще одна
перемога України
у генштабі ЗСУ кажуть що поки не можуть
підтвердити чи спростувати інформацію
про виведення російських військ з
Херсона за кожним так званим жестом
доброї волі противника стоять колосальні
зусилля українських військ наголосив
головнокомандувач ЗСУ Валерій залужний